there's this logical fallacy that is
sort of informally called what about ISM
in some circles and Donald Trump when
interviewed on Fox News on Air Force One
coming back from the Singapore summit
with Kim jong-un was asked by Brett
Beier about how he can say all these
nice things about Kim jong-un despite
the fact that he is a brutal dictator
that there are murders for starvation
all sorts of human rights and other
abuses and Donald Trump jumped headfirst
into what about ISM where he basically
pointed out that number one listen Kim
jong-un inherited a brutal regime for
from his father so in some sense I guess
that excuses his being a brutal dictator
and murdering people and also pointed
out that there are other countries that
also do bad things which again is not
actually an argument because we have no
obligation to deal with those countries
if we don't want we have no obligation
to praise their leaders as Trump did Kim
jong-un is smart talented and a very
good negotiator and a very funny guy and
a guy with a great personality right you
can recognize that there are bad people
around the world or brutal people around
the world in addition to Kim jong-un
without necessarily praising all of them
so I'm gonna play this clip for you it
is Brett Bayer interviewing Donald Trump
on Air Force One it is a horrible
horrible incoherent explanation for why
he all of a sudden thinks Kim jong-un is
so great you were asked in the press
conference a number of different times
in different ways about human rights and
you know that you called this
relationship really good and that he was
a very talented person
you know you call people sometimes
killers you know he is a killer he's
executing people hey when you take over
a country tough country tough people and
you take it over from your father I
don't care who you are what you are how
much of an advantage you have if you
could do that at 27 years old you I mean
that's one in 10,000 that could do that
so he's a very smart guy he's a great
negotiator but I think we understand
each other
but he still some done some really bad
things yeah but so of a lot of other
people done some really bad things I
mean I could go through a lot of nations
where a lot of bad things were done now
but we're not praising the leaders of
all of those nations and we're not doing
deals where we give everything away and
get nothing verifiable or guaranteed in
return this interview so there were a
ton of interviews that were done with
Trump after the summit there was the
Georges stuff it will not it not a time
there was the George Stephanopoulos
interview notably there was the Bret
Baier interview there were a couple more
major interviews that I'm forgetting now
and then the results are the press
conference right during which questions
were asked of Donald Trump this 55
second clip with Bret Baier is actually
the most disturbing in exposing what
Donald Trump's mentality here is which
seems to be a sort of self-rationalizing
based on bad things have happened in the
world before and thus we shouldn't be at
all worried that I handed over to a
brutal brutal dictator a whole bunch of
stuff that he wanted and by the way came
up with proactive praise of him this is
really really scary to me because of the
precedent that it sets it's scary to me
because by virtue of being on Fox News a
ton of people will either never see it
because they don't watch fox or people
who do watch Fox won't find anything
unusual about the commentary but this
this is really really dangerous stuff
and the other reason it's dangerous and
I'm curious whether you agree Pat is
that Trump we observe these
authoritarian tendencies on Trump's
behalf he seems to be in some way
enamored with people like president air
Dewan of Turkey he thought it was just
amazingly great when the Chinese
President made it so that he could just
continuously be reelected to president
and said sort of half jokingly maybe we
would sometimes try that here Trump
thinking that these brutal dictators are
really great people and smart and great
negotiators is very scary to us and and
I think that we should all be very
afraid of what is going on here yeah
Rodrigo Duterte Vladimir Putin he'll
praise dictators but you're a
democratically elected leader you won't
necessarily get that praise and I also
love how he was able to compliment
himself within that comment right well
yes like Kim jong-un was 27 years old
took over for his father and went on to
lead a country kind of sounds like Trump
right he took over for his BA
the Trump Organization yes such a
beautiful business turned it into a
beautiful business and it is the
business of the presidency at this point
for Donald Trump one in 10,000
absolutely disgusting what we are seeing
from Trump and I wish that some on the
right would say I want to get along with
other countries I am a still a
Republican but this can't be allowed
this can't be allowed because it signals
a dangerous retreat into horrible
ideologies we have a fantastic program
for you today I'm really glad you're
here with us on the Friday show we will
take some calls we will review a great
interview from the archives we will
answer some audience questions and much
much more